welcome everyone to stream Coco how's it
going big day today we voted we voted
everybody we voted there you got warm
America shirt today cuz we voted we're
late cuz I we voted we can say that
we're not we were actually having a
meeting about the team coco podcast
which we're gonna revive coming soon
that's right so that is very exciting
and today we're playing a game that all
of you have wanted us to play for a long
time you voted we listen to you it's
called dead space 3
I've never played dead space before I've
never played dead space 3 before I've
ever plays dead place 2 before this is
my first time what's going on everybody
all this monitor is jacked off over here
Merc what's up mega brother X I could be
good to see you sorry a debt dam and
preet that we started late I don't know
what's happening here don't contact me I
agree let's do it we're getting into
this no what is happing skip this
[ __ ] thank you solo campaign yes
please
now all I know what this game is it
takes place in space and oh I always do
the brightnesses max as possible I feel
like that's pretty good right fair
enough
there's all these ice blocks with these
blocks of ice well should we go normal
or hard guys normal are hard what do you
think noob I'm a noob
from America all right here we go we're
in space this is earth elevator
simulator someone says dead space 3 over
here I mean I love an elevator
[Music]
I love it normal says Frank tank I know
no Red Dead we're sorry it didn't oh my
god what the hell's going on this this
lets me get a pure one Oh God
who likes snow globes he likes
eight-ball good heart
impossible or no balls I've no balls hey
Rammstein reg good to see you jungle gym
mania what's going on say my name say my
name a Teemo 1985 there you go
[Music]
somebody explain to me what this is
about because I'm not I think it's
probably just like the world is ending
probably because of Technology okay yeah
oh I see it's limitless energy from the
black marker but I think it's like
cursed energy just like the blue cube
what's the blue you
oh yeah the Cosmic Cube yeah oh [ __ ] Oh
oh my god damn so it turns people in
dead
oh god this is awful it's pew-pew kill
monsters to talk to me planet cracker
that's what I get that for you Taco Bell
Planet cracker sorry
ancient alien evil it's all we need to
know as I say thank you
whoa Oh God think of the eye Jesus
Christ what is this game they were
playing oh my God look the eye of Zara I
think so
planet cracking equals fracking got it
[Music]
it didn't download in time guys I'm
sorry I'm already late so we wanted to
start so we start with Dead Space 3 I
promise you would be playing some red
that's like my favorite game he's got a
cool leather jacket though so wait a
second the markers now are around
do you think we get to meet this
narrator I but she's like pretty hot I
bet she looks like kind of like Rachel
vice sounds like her in the mummy it
does yeah exactly
sounds like Rachel vices love me I saw
the lobster by the way did you guys see
the lobster yeah it's a it's good it's
weird
my mom hated it it's not a metallica
shirt it's a murica shirt there you go
America America clicking all right stick
lose look this is gonna be a problem
already there's a locator read and read
and read is that true Red Dead
Redemption they coming back the lobster
farts fair enough the second game is
better why would I play three before any
others because that's the only one we
had in our office people told me I
should play this game and we download it
it's a physical Tara not Red Dead
Redemption is also one of my favorite
games we could talk about Red Dead
Redemption all day today if you want to
it's a dead space spoiler you die
correct what's going on Edgar's gaming
today good to see you
it didn't download on what Luke Vader on
Xbox 360 it didn't download all right
there's snow why don't play Mirror's
Edge catalyst yes - link what I
absolutely will be playing that I just
got the della code for that gave the
engineers the priests ever like come up
common guys two games one week respect
the expense account first of all I am
the producer and no I never knew that
person I'm terrible with money so I seen
it do keep your mask up keep your mask
up it's an ancient machine the Xbox 360
Xbox 360 is still great plant coops as
Isiah D we could I guess the Rockstar
servers are down due to GTA V update Oh
bond go are you lying to us interesting
that could be it
we couldn't find I have read that
Redemption the physical copy but we
couldn't find it so because we just
redid our whole studio and everything oh
there it goes I've been worried about
all those interlocking pieces so close
to my face you know what I'm saying
there we go
yeah boy you know I have I do like this
game the that it's all kind of like your
life is like on your back and stuff you
know so it's like it doesn't take you
out of the game with like a hug yeah am
I going the right way
no one knows oh there we go bear ski 180
dead space series one of the reasons I
have an xbox 360 perfect there's a
secret in the first level of this game
what key bear what is this guys what's
the secret I have a mask why am I
putting my hand in front
oh yeah that's a good idea sorry what do
we think it's under baby 600
and I move faster than this it's a
minimalistic @hud I love games that do
that I agree me too it's very cool
please say my name mile high was at 420
perfect
oh man YouTube chat is just you guys are
on fire today
hi you guys are not fire today YouTube
to everyone guys crazy
Able's alright here we go president lb
let's run I love a Mallee just laughing
at you it's true it never gets old bad
on YouTube goddamn right I can get
inside I pick the stuff up what is this
oh wait I can stop containers here we go
oh yeah
boom it's also hi dance pretty great I'm
guessing I can't shoot my way inside
right it's like to pick a back up a can
Oh
boom let's get in there
[Music]
oh one of my all-time favorite oh Jesus
Oh God holy Sh what the dude we're into
it already I love it it's real like a
melee here other is okay push him off
the cliff
Oh No what the hell oh this guy is
definitely gonna die right this T's
definitely gonna die like in a second
[Music]
uh even without a head
come on dude even without a head
oh that's crap what should I do you
shoot him in the legs maybe ya been the
king ah ah Jesus Christ
[Music]
good god man are you kidding me you're
kidding me with this
how's it dude not dead oh stop him stop
him
it gets crazy to shoot their limbs not
their heads oh now you tell me I can't
shoot their heads good god man
well my minimal HUD is saying what was
dead so that's cool
Jesus God
schema scheme is like already scary
Jesus Christ I'm dead I'm gonna die
oh my god
I've liked zero life it's cool music on
this this is horrifying this game is
absolutely horrifying oh this bed yet
screw this guy man okay yes start a
blade death counter you're gonna want
that yep just quickly you can't get me
if he doesn't have any arms right ah see
I knew it I knew it well you don't have
any arms now so good luck trying to hug
your loved ones can be hard for you show
love Wow why would what is that weird
humming someone that the monsters get
more grotesque how is it possible what
is that weird noise dudes serve
resources I'm sorry Terra not I wasn't
exactly thinking of conserving
[Music]
superboy have like a flashlight up in
here or open yes please
this guy's one side watch over vents
yeah well what's this this guy is not
Isaac Clark so we're gonna die yeah see
I knew it oh my god
holy crap this guy yeah he's very oh my
god
huh this is crazy I just spit up by the
way the key to everything
key to everything Jesus
Oh Mike yeah I died I died what happened
I don't even know what happened
right on the side of a mountain bro well
I'm definitely gonna die if it's the key
to saving everything at the beginning of
the game we're definitely gonna die here
[Music]
can't I just rappel down the entire
[Music]
Jesus holy jesus
[Music]
oh my god there's no way there's no way
I'm just rolling back and forth oh my
god holy crap dude what the we're fine
see it's a good thing I put my helmet up
again we're good holy crap Zig when I
should have zagged so I hope I rose I
suck thank you appreciate it appreciate
your patience oh those are nice boots
hmm but you people got hung here or
hanged
this dude is definitely gonna kill us
right we can't survive we're not the
hero so we're definitely gonna die here
earl serrano that's your duty boom
six out of ten there's this kind of a
dick sometimes I'm gonna shoot it I'm
gonna shoot you shoot him yep I knew it
of course you should have said no if
something says do you love the earth say
no mine deleting oh no it's the key to
everything though it was a pretty easy
key to delete why also just upload it to
the cloud so then the key is just in the
cloud yeah oh oh plot twist
kills himself alright that's not the bad
guy
[Music]
- liquid the only problem of dead space
3 Oh data purged is that it's not as
scary as the first two Dame's are you
seriously yeah I didn't hold the door
well played
I loved it
[Music]
why would you have him oh I see I
thought the doors in space that's all
this looks like LA in about 20 years
yeah 200 yeah maybe 200 I feel like if
there was a planet that closed though it
would destroy this planet with their
gravity
this game isn't realistic all right this
is us so now now this is we've got a
cool jacket yeah exactly ready to go got
a drinking problem huh
he's very serious the first dead space
is the scariest game of all time really
way more action II I mean I think in
this one you're probably like already
like in in plot mode you know this we
started a survival horror games we're a
circus more useless stuff and damage the
sloughs trenches is slow to act or
action or Oh Thank You Sheldon
don't talk back to this guy our mission
so these markers basically are ruining
the universe these these check these
markers I don't know
Sharpie markers sharpies Isaak used to
be a mute now he's fine to talk to you
for some reason it's like Jacob's Ladder
and space Jacobs letters have got a guy
spoiler alert who's actually about to
die phone's gonna die sorry soccer man
get a charger all right I'll help you
let's go okay okay
what do I played Star Wars alchemy good
question
maybe next week that's me don't take a
picture yourself you self-involved
a-hole
this guy looks pretty good take a
picture again yeah it is a rude
awakening
it feels very blade runner-esque yeah
well I've ruined my mirror never like
clean their apartments
I know although then again I don't
really clean my apartment either it does
that actually looks exactly like this so
there's I found a huge roach in my
apartment you want to see a picture you
guys want to see a picture of the road
to fender man shake the set I think we
all want to see it it's gonna freak you
out it looks fake it is the most problem
it looks it looks like a fake thing this
is gonna freak you out
oh if that's a quarter that's a quarter
it's
it's a quarter for reference by the way
that's terrible yeah that's not good
nobody likes right there you go pretty
scary I should move but you know I'm
lazy dead space for is there a dead
space forward can I stop on things oh
yeah I like the stomping mode in this
red moon apartments alright graffitis on
point
let's have a deep conversation now this
sounds like a good idea no I'm helping
you putting my life on the line how
about less smart aleck comments Jesus
marry Blade Runner
well we moved to
hold still guy our fans are really
hoping Oh is this new part of Earth
Gove's oh Jesus oh you boy just blew
himself up dead space for is like
half-life 3 right this just combined the
two games Jesus oh this is this is a
nightmare
down here
[Music]
I gotta have a different gun now oh wait
this is did I see that's like
[Music]
but they just bash this dude's head in I
guess I can is the answer
Jesus language bro
I shoot him in the crotch that's my
favorite place to shoot somebody
I'm just not doing well with this ah
[Music]
I'm dead no I'm still alive yeah when I
try to kill me man
I'm dead Oh oh wow they come in half why
they trying to kill me
all right ketchup time Unitologist are a
cult which worships the markers markers
are ancient obelisks which can be a
source of limitless power but also have
the unfortunate side-effect with
constant madness with session
reanimating the dead is Necromorphs all
right something so basically people like
people who like Family Guy okay yeah oh
there's more oh there's more
all right by the time of DTS 3 the area
you live in has been taken over by the
cult who believe who believe because
they worship the marker they can never
truly die got it
thirsty can that punch definitely
destroyed
so can I like cut people's limbs off or
what's the deal here how do you punch
someone and remove their legs it
whatever it is this gun is
[Music]
[Music]
all right well I can shoot these dudes
in the head so it gives with that
[Music]
for this way
music is very intense intense intense
intense go over the course of the first
two games we've discovered markers this
is madness and destroyed markers the
cult wants us to die
ooh the reason that we know how to
destroy markers is because we know how
to make more oh I see
weave it's like we are the coda whoa
wait so we have to destroy humanity
basically right so we're Trump yeah I
don't get it it's climbing this ladder
then face extraction that we explained
so much of what's going on all three
times explains the origin much better
and more clear well explain it to me or
that's what it is is this like an iPhone
12 yeah what does that yeah he's the
chosen one got it
the game focuses on dismemberment is a
feature because Necromorphs don't die
you effectively dismember them so they
become ineffective over things like
headshots so kill just makes it crazy oh
wait so I shouldn't shoot people in the
head well good because I was I was doing
pretty poor anyway
[Music]
oh don't kill that
[Music]
I go this way nope okay stop the sky
stop them stop them
[Music]
ah whoa
Jesus Christ and they're driving very
close together oh here we go we're gonna
learn a new skill guys I love this stop
now stop tomorrow stop particularly
thank you Amy press Y all right whoa
oh man we're definitely gonna bill me
for this here we go let's go
good one good one Isaac
it's like anti resident evil
survival-horror Donnell headshots what
the guys please you're just wasting your
anymo games all about stopping that's
I'm learning
[Music]
go this way can't go this way
[Music]
these dudes are alive these dudes are
alive these dudes are alive
nope other people in there no weapon
switch
[Music]
wait
this what I want so does it imagine
their back problems everyone in games is
always crouching it's true I don't like
this dude like oh it looks like an old
McLovin oh god that's a terrible statue
this scheme is very graphic make us
whole I don't know ice culture 81 maybe
next week you know what maybe starting
with the third installing the series
wasn't the smartest idea why do I feel
like this is just a prologue and
everything is going to corp you know
where do whatever there's a corp
something bad you know whenever the g3
45 kepler gets delayed yeah I knew it
see I knew it so that we can watch a
previously on dead space like things in
this game putting him yeah how's that
look like I don't know crossbows rejects
we're just trying to make space great
again that's true you think that is
Bryan Cranston maybe I love this you're
gonna be done in a few minutes
here's some bad lucky to save I'll
explain really
[Music]
yeah that counts like Bill Nye and Bill
Nye not the science guy but you know the
other guy I'm telling you this guy's
just trying to make space great again
ah Mustaine 75 well played try looking
around oh no oh oh that's not good yeah
that's uh no wait now everyone's gonna
turn into a crazy oh nice yeah boy
now I'm just gonna turn to a crazy
Necromorph right Beauty Seltzer's in
here doing probably not
sounds like David Warner you're right
yes and Joe that probably is to everyone
you know the guy was in Time Bandits you
know David Warner the devil in Time
Bandits yeah oh yeah yeah yes do we
gotta have my pops well here we go
just another day at the office a killing
Necromorphs all right so our back to
these dudes yeah
can I change it this other gun god damn
it oh jesus what holy [ __ ] dude what is
going on I gotta change my other crazy
gun this is this is extremely uncool
very uncool very uncool my god holy [ __ ]
that was why she lives this remember
thank you thank you
I gotta remember to stomp stomp
oh my god I don't look like a play he
just thing to you yeah exactly
well I got this gun now I got my
dismemberment gun which is really the
only gun you need kids
that was what had happened there these
are like med packs I think
man come on guys come
oh that's Oh a plasma cutter is better
to rotate horizontal vertical to
dismember people more than a gun yeah I
got my plasma here we go see you there
we go see we can do this yeah I'm gonna
keep it this way because then I feel
like because I feel like then I can I
can get their legs look at look at this
thing by the way oh my god what is that
that is awful there was a shoot limbs
then getting close and stomp oh my god
dude this game is awesome I'm in do we
think things are gonna come back to life
a lot if you don't stop you know if you
don't stop them yeah ah oh this place is
a mess oh it's already bad enough cuz it
looks like our office is hell on earth
here we go oh this is cool I'm a fan
oh look at that look at the marker
glowing get him in the legs get him in
the legs and stop them ah Jesus Christ
dude on frickin cool get him in the legs
bro
get him in the legs broke get him in the
legs bro no what is that thing what is
it doing that oh my god I can't even
ah ah it's shooting some of me this game
is so messed up man this game is crazy
can I shoot that thing off oh my god
what is that noise I would just if this
was real life I would just kill myself
I mean I would just kill myself right we
don't want to live in a world but these
things yeah I don't think we're gonna
turn it around yeah we're not going
right we're not coming back
humanity's not coming back from this oh
the kitchens a mess
somebody could slip and all this blood
on the floor you know late Oh hashtag
blade stop there you go oh hey I found
all the extra chairs oh you're there yes
you know it's like oh my god just a
little bit of blood look at that look
exactly like all right but here's what I
hope happened I hope that before all
this [ __ ] went down somebody was playing
a prank and hiding all the chairs he's
like oh there's gonna be so funny and
then the marker opens that ever it turns
into things try to have a meeting yet oh
my god dude do a quick ammo run here
what kind of boots do you think are best
for stomping corpses like what's a good
like maybe should we asked she would go
to REI and ask our yeah actually she
would call REI right now let's call him
yes can you look up the number for REI
yep they do it online
again weekend no I'm actually serious I
think we should call REI yeah should be
caught you guys should we call REI and
ask them what the best boot for like you
know stuff at corpses would be you think
that might they might call way maybe on
a chat maybe what I open a chat maybe
that might be better cuz I got to play
the game online live help yeah am I
getting back in the elevator I guess I
am
oh it's not live it's not live chat oh
there it is yeah go live chat just be
like we're playing a video game to tell
it we don't want to we don't want to get
out on some kind of list listen I don't
think I want my IP address oh it's gonna
be the shows aren't via
that means thirsty Kansas that would
definitely put you on a list you're not
gonna run for public office I just oh no
I'm just curious like what do you think
the best can you look up boot reviews
yeah look up some boot reviews why don't
you say instead of oh no instead of
stopping heads what about like stopping
watermelons oh that's a clogger part do
some ones that Jordan would know just
ask George actually Jordan probably
would know wait can you ask him can you
just email it for me a lot of screaming
going on like not like good screaming
like Bieber screaming like mercury like
Moritz real murder II
I feel like when you stop when you stop
someone corpse oh you're gonna want a
good steel toe yeah you're gonna want
something waterproof clearly why is
everyone running am I like in like a
this is like this is a terrible mall by
the way it's very claustrophobic who
maybe like a variation of like a
snowshoes
oh yeah somebody said crampons yeah
we're like oh yeah grandpa wait I just
messed up how did I mess up the big
stout boot from Mario 3 here we go wait
didn't I do this am I supposed to go
back down
[ __ ] I'm going backwards here yeah drive
my locator objective this way this is
cool it tells you where to go
I wish all games had that by the way
congratulations dead space 3 you have
something really cool Oh watch the
animated movie dead space downfall which
is a prequel of first game I will sort
from Kingdom Hearts and his shoes to be
a suitable for the situation hand yet oh
this is they're talking about the
elevator thing oh yeah we're already a
hell of an elevator for 1,300 like what
says just a case stop everything looks
suspicious like the zombie Lane double
tap rule don't get stingy with amma for
not sure it's dead thank you
[Music]
it's uh probably something good in their
party there's a party oh geez
this is we've guys we found the scariest
yeah
found the scariest thing of the game is
you know my con nope no where's it
coming from
smell medpac I'll pick that up be very
unhappy very unhappy about this Jesus
Christ stop it please stop it I'm not
gonna shoot that thing I know it wants
me to I'm not gonna do it let's go it's
like a rocket my stomach Chris do you
guys supposed to keep your your limb
cutters like this or like this
are you a horizontal limb cutter you got
score Azana are you guys vertical limb
cutters what do I want like help me out
because I'm going to die a thousand
times - no not a fan not a fan of that
thing nope nope nope nope nope oh Jesus
God
oh come on no oh my god this is terrible
this is awful this is the worst thing
I've ever played in my life oh now I'm
out of those bullets oh [ __ ] god dammit
oh this game sucks no just run away I'm
running away
f those guys oh there's more guys down
here er er er open the door open the
door no Jesus open the door yeah in your
face get in - get in the thing get in
the thing close the door thank you just
stay in the elevator make a little home
elevator five of 10,000 oh it's real
quiet up here don't say that
yeah Joey I got jumpscared yes have you
been watching dude do you see those
things how are you just cool at this
rate we got a puzzle stupid how does
this work great now we have to make a
train Harsha ceaseless have Kinesis Oh
Oh what
that's what I do I did that I do this
and this this and this then I do this
right messing this up
[Music]
things like we show this going let's see
let's try this
uh-oh Aries been out such a long time
since I've Kinesis to Train yeah
oh this looks right come this way pal
[Music]
konista we can east it means to [ __ ] on
a train oh my god
real drinks yeah we actually did we
basically did steal all this stuff yeah
so you're not far off this is not
sponsored nope I swear way too much I
think yeah this could never be no or we
talk a lot too much of those who own
emotion may be nice to play still
intermission we don't know where do I go
now and if somebody help me yes well
that's not gonna work
oh it is just like the force or someone
said that oh yeah I love it look we have
the forest Lee but why doesn't he use
Kinesis to like rip apart like ten yeah
just like push away all the tentacle
dudes bro oh my god you see like we were
just living like a bubble of our kanaeva
yeah I've got to do that again all right
here we go uh nope blocked you need to
do more Kinesis joy never coming here
why about scientific and actions as Man
1 he has come in here before and
everyone freaked out so hard that nobody
asked him any questions and then he just
was like why am i coming down here and
then like yeah you guys blew it he did
come down here and everybody blew it you
know what you can't jump in this game
and that's a problem for me cuz I like
to jump just randomly I just like
jumping uh let's see here we got this
[Music]
oh I see I'm supposed to maybe now push
this if we've killed the dudes of Lance
or spike on it we can rip this bike off
and launch it at other people power
great uh what what do you mean the Lance
Oh like one of the when the guy turns
into like the evil t1000 things yep
that's right pal move it back move it
back let's go this is a little sloppy
control I'm gonna say that right off the
bat here okay no problem I got this
nailed here comes the fuel car coming
right up on fuel car at your service not
the easiest thing to do here at the
Kinesis how am I doing this by the way
like it's my suit is there a battery all
right we hooked it up let's go this
train looks safe let's get on this all
those arcing electricity great I can't
jump though I can't jump I can't jump
you know what ten bucks says it's gonna
there's gonna be 50 yeah dude I can't
get on this train bro it's not gonna be
easy
oh really I wonder if there's bad guys
all over this train yeah I'm unhappy
with this yeah
yeah she turned to a thing with a
million tentacles bro I like how they
put X and capitals your ex-girlfriend
bro get over her she doesn't love you
anymore she never did know what that's
like
ah Jesus what the [ __ ] well then why did
I open that door where these good guys
are bad guys what's happening oh Jesus
we crash wait I got it hey I gotta
change guns to my other gun my people
killing gun where's my people killing
young here it is yeah why do we open the
door that was dumb shoot the guy in the
crotch I always do that it sends a
message to the other guys don't shoot at
me cuz I'll shoot you in the crotch - oh
my god do you see what's going on back
here man
[Music]
I'm gonna stop you so hard I can't jump
of course too bad I can't jump down
there like any other human being would
do ever just cash yeah I take your time
Isaac oh I can still stop time let's
remember that because I might need to do
that soon probably telling me though I'm
on a moon ecology I can't read that
right now I'm about to die
we just want to be left alone if you
just but they're trying to use us for
our knowledge
yeah nice did it did it got it you know
that takes a lot of
let's go let's go
[Music]
guys who beat the game that game was
really short
we didn't buy that game cuz I feel like
that would've been such a [ __ ] you know
what a [ __ ] we're on xbox360 today this
is probably just the epilogue chapter
one right now chapter number one we look
sweaty and you we must smell terrible in
those suits let's take a shower if
they're like a shower level now I kind
of feel like anybody at any time to just
be like what about if this is just it
turns out it's just a virulent strain of
eczema eczema yes you know like you just
need like some cortisone cream and just
like back to sleep ooh we're given the
chance between Necromorphs and
Unitologist left both factions Duke it
out first they kill their survivors
that's a great tip delinquent is one of
the only people helping me and I
appreciate it that's right washes us oh
it doesn't look that complex mm-hmm does
that how does it it's like a like what
do you mean I'd like some more this is
always the most boring parts a game
something like the corners no one cares
cuz I never know if I'm supposed like
look around to find stuff and just like
no this is called the plot part love you
dad yeah guess what I saw this in and
they did this in with that interstellar
movie which by the way that was a great
part in interstellar or he watches all
the messages I send Martian hey look at
the space guitar thank you it's a space
banjo everybody can we play it exactly
what's that be you're go stream
overwatch have fun
if you guys missed it we did a fun
clueless gamer with Peter Dinklage and
Lena Headey we played overwatch Peter
Dinklage is really good actually at
overwatch it's just crazy that was
really fun we don't care about this
let's go I'm back to killing thing
Necromorphs can only be formed a dead
flesh gross neck and orcs are
instinctive but cannot communicate if
they're talking as they die first they
won't get all technically this ship is
hard to navigate little claustrophobic
it's a lot of mists everywhere whoa
what's happening whoa cool let's say dr.
you thing are we gonna giant TARDIS King
Mern a giant artist well it might not be
giant on the outside well played well
played well played all right just
running around here oh wait let's use
our thing going the wrong way
thank lord I like blue simmers better
than just you and Conan play thank you
very much although I'm we're working on
some that I think you guys are gonna be
happy about
Conan unfortunately doesn't like to play
with just me anymore so it's now just
celebrities I hope you like it
how do you pilot a ship into a giant
light yeah like it I don't just gotta be
quick okay that guys on that guy's got
it
it's got like a big real thing I'll get
ready for the D shotgun oh man
sit tight
here we are at a planet say it that's no
moon say it
No oh snap
where are we these are probably all of
our those suits really are very
form-fitting yeah
graver that's called space bro a space
is dead wick Wilke prodigy soon you'll
be very familiar of flickering lights
for some reason lights eyes flicker in
space yeah a pretty good man it sure
abigai space in a complex way but we
can't get like light bulbs
I know exactly that function or the
other dude is one of the other Oh what
is this Galaxy Quest mines
we're so [ __ ] it's like a comedy of
errors like a dead space nerd keep it
well done thank you howler that's very
nice of you to say Roanoke its to Galaxy
Quest berry Sando Galaxy Quest amazing
whoa what that guy just turn into like
holy crap dude put your thing up
why don't I mean weapons all the air is
going out of the I'm dead I'm dead
my oh my leg
all right I gotta get out of here all
right we gotta go this way get out of
here
[Music]
get the weapon get the weapon I'm not
sure what happened to our leg we should
cut herself shaving says why are you
giving the orders dude just do it
there's no one trained on this ship like
are you all supposed to be highly
trained people what is this Prometheus
[Music]
how did you guys get into space without
some sort of a great Oh gravity offline
uh oh uh uh 0g fire is really bad 0g
fires very buff gravity's back on all
right awesome
that just swell some glass that's not
good man all these things are about to
crack no way this is gonna go well I
wish I could jump that would certainly
help in this situation don't you think
right or run I am kind of running all
those people are dead okay fair enough
get in the suit get in the suit get in
the suit get in the suit put the suit on
get in the suit now I'm extra-large not
my size I'm a double X what if this was
me the suit would just be like a little
too small and I would die
[Music]
Oh get that helmet on bro get that
helmet on bro yeah this is actually our
Master Chief was made here we go pop SLB
boom
oh so this will be a section where I die
50 times here we go
[Music]
no way this is gonna work right how do I
release the clamps oh I like there's
just a big arrow there you go do I do
just go up to the thing
[Music]
how do I release the clamps everyone
[Music]
wait seriously how did this clamps get
released is there like a clamp release
button anyone maybe this side am I
supposed to shoot something by shooting
these clamps slowly that's working very
well
[Music]
in space no one can hear you ask how do
I release the glass oh we can use our
power oh right the telekinesis power
wait how do we do that again it's this
oh there we go
yep got it thank you thanks a lot
appreciate it all right find something
to hold hold on to your butts
[Music]
yep release please oh yeah oh thank
goodness that explosion waited for us
before you figured out how to connect
those clamps off yeah
[Music]
why aren't the mines going after the
other thing shoot oh boy oh Jesus look
at where you're like jeb Corliss yeah
hopefully we're not exactly jeb Corliss
cuz we just turned into paste I think he
just has hurt his leg once yeah bro I
see and bro get in those mines this is
gotta go through the doorway paste paste
paste dude chill out do you see what I'm
doing right now just shut up can you
wait five minutes for me to get through
all these mines and Space wreckage where
were you man shut up god damn it just a
bunch of whiners in space you should
just die why am I even helping you I'm
never gonna die anyway by the way yeah
all of our friends yeah you're gonna and
then you're gonna turn to Necromorphs
then you're gonna have a bunch of
tentacles
what's through it yeah if there's a
checkpoint that I wanted to do it again
but otherwise it's always going after a
girl you know just let her die let her
die you cares there's other fish in the
sea you know yeah that's the thing
here's the thing all right
if you if the zombie apocalypse happens
all right and your boyfriend or
girlfriend is stuck across town let them
die let him die don't go together number
one number one is yourself and yes you
have to worry about number one yeah
don't worry I'll take care of it why
don't you just bug me every five minutes
you don't have saying just let him die
who cares nothing you could do about it
anyway that's how you get yourself
killed
hold with Kinesis then press B to turn
alright well I like how there's like no
sound because it's like space that's
kind of cool
just let them get the right guys just
let him die what about love you know
what when it comes to zombies what about
love for yourself you know what I'm
saying yeah put your hands until you how
can you find the cure for the zombie
apocalypse if you're chasing take grim
you're like gonna make it to drinks
later yeah exactly drink
all right where am I going what do I do
here
what can ISA sing I think so so blue is
basically Kinesis anytime blue happens I
think we do Kinesis I'll kill myself at
space and leave my lover behind truth
comes out that's true that's exactly
what I would do you need to have these
are conversations you need to have with
your loved one yeah or you know what
like war you would you want children
what what would we do no this is before
the children conversation yeah so
basically basically you need guys as a
PSA from Beth and I or maybe just me to
the internet I don't know if I approve
you need to have a conversation with
your loved one slash loved ones if a
zombie apocalypse happens what's the
plan what's the plan
are you gonna meet up at some place are
you gonna try to go across town cuz
here's the other thing let's say I'm
trying to go across town the best place
she's coming across town to my place
yeah that's just confused that's just
confusing for everybody now Beth and I
know I would just leave her to die so
she knows not to come get me or me to go
get her so it's fine we've have a pact
we figured it out yeah it's just every
person for themselves it's like the
opposite of like if like if no one is
married when they're 40 we'll get
married right like the opposite of that
it's like opposite if we were both in
grave danger neither of us would give a
[ __ ] that's true exactly and being 40 by
the way is being in grave danger so
there you go it also except you need to
have this talk with your loved ones
before it's too late guys rule number
five is Zombieland no attachments see
rule 17 don't be a hero let them die
Thank You Kenny man zombie land is life
yeah agreed 100% oh it's locked with
Mike
nice as I can tell that's how we do man
zombie lay man also cardio cardio cardio
always I think there's any like good
[ __ ] I can look a bay like around here
that's somebody left on the space
station this love eBay and the
Necromorph world people still need goods
yeah good services I agree here we go
I'm supposed to do something these boxes
probably Hey Oh what happened oh no I
didn't want to stasis it guess some
boxes aren't unstoppable I should have
been my high school quote Tech's from
play yeah but that's like ten minutes to
the opposite direction I'm gonna save
myself
please read by nature I'm never gonna
there's no way I'm gonna text somebody
why would I waste it text grave danger
fits with dead space you're right what's
up Patricia Riviera juice right I human
you know that's proof that I'm human
let's do we need one of those captured
things what would a real-life CAPTCHA
test be oh that's good
it would be something like maybe it was
some like a really really sad footage of
something so Jordan would failed again
yeah you have maybe well that's just I
mean you can be human you can be a
psychopath so that maybe doesn't work
sure you can
I think that's always coming from deeper
inside this ship but I can't believe
Rosalynn Locke why does it le come out
and she knows things are going on that's
straight too far all right man
how about can it order be like just
helping you who's this dude it's our
friend must be I don't like his helmet
scary
[Music]
Louis loot everything I'm not sure how
loot stuff
this game me I will say this game is
very scary
now I'm think I should play Dead Space 1
cutter or horizontal for ankles and
kneecaps horizontal for wrist elbow
shoulder ok so you mean they believe me
vertical for wrist elbow yeah I think
there's a Necromorph or two around here
that's I'm going to plasma cutter yeah
wonder what their quarantine
oh I don't know Necromorphs how do these
guys just know how to do this you know
what I'm saying
and why are we opening um frickin your
own up Saint let it alone man why are we
poking the beach don't poke the Beast
bro WTF it's big a WTF we have Marc
Maron on the show tomorrow yeah who's on
the show today we got our old friend di
Nicole's coming back he's on Angie's
first panel I think that's right he's
not Angie Tribeca this is not going in
there like it should and I Dana Carvey
today Danny Kirby's today also unknown
Mortal Orchestra I think they're playing
a Grateful Dead song called shakedown
Street train for every situation except
for if a hole gets blown in the ship
then they don't know what to do how does
this go in there we don't know we have
to do something else for a static oh
whoops
oh wait whoops I messed up she had this
thing in real life would be so much
easier like make toast and stuff should
we craft a weapon let's craft something
it's like that part in The Sims where
you can make a table I don't know that
part what are you talking about [ __ ]
craft event spec why would I make a
bedside table to do a crafty that's
ridiculous okay okay all right yep got
it default it crafting is the best part
in this game I think they're good yeah
yeah I think they're as an upper tool a
lower tool military engine a good point
can you make toast in there I'm starving
oh that's so hungry no let's skip it
yeah let's skip it no wait let's make it
oh alright here we go
I think the plasma carpet we're gonna
want to upgrade this weapon for sure
this is our main or tech can't do that
default tip plasma core okay this is
gonna help us
someone said we barely have any parts
okay great
all right done we did it that's sure
what we did probably no wrote a
fanfiction starting delay the Hedgehog
perfect send it to us the Hedgehog story
what's all that sex stuff right now I
see a sex Hedgehog stuff because I
respect hedgehogs as creature desert
[Music]
alright there's definitely dead guys in
here why am i opening this well let's go
let this girl die we don't care it's one
person they just think about in terms if
there's like how many pillar on the ship
three or four went through all that
stuff we dodged all the mines we've done
that stuff and now we're gonna go after
one person this is ridiculous bloody
handprints this is dumb what are we
doing this is so dumb why am i opening
these doors this is stupid we have a
curious mind knack send Conan does play
sometimes he hasn't played a little
while but blob and come back soon enough
that's a very bad noise let's open more
doors this is the dumbest thing I've
ever done I haven't found anything bad
yet let's wait and hold out for that
man no no no no no no no no no thank you
no thank you no thank you no thank you
no thanks no thanks dude I am totally
cutting this dude's legs off it just
[Music]
died now shut up they're in a game
called dead space 3 everything survives
thank you delinquent
[Music]
I throw these things I can't can I I
know Gingras pinger says I like how they
just make you stand there while hops
down I know just like Bing Bing Bing
Bing Bing dead dead dead dead dead oh
[Music]
great
you know it's giving you a tip shoot
limbs for extra damage I'm gonna be in
some [ __ ] in about a second
all right well no let's get to
dismembering oh good we're in a theater
oh this is great yeah I'm sure there's
nothing hiding in here slash
everything's hiding in here slash that
thing right there what the [ __ ] is that
thing
mad now but I did shoot it by the way
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey I shot
you dude hey pal mother dude I shot your
ass all right you know what I'm running
away forget you guys
you guys are no fun thank you no thank
you I don't want to hear that you know
you guys today kind of run away from I
don't get you son of a [ __ ]
there's so many of them
[Music]
just Jesus Christ
[Music]
Oh God that is redonkulous I don't get
how their legs are not getting shot off
am I not shooting them in the legs
you guys saw that right no I'm just not
doing it properly
someone said when you shoot then I just
makes them angry yeah no [ __ ] I get
angry too my being shower the plasma
cutter didn't do anything oh my god it
was awful well yeah they were busy
watching the movie yeah they're so
pissed I really wanted to watch it in
peace you come in here and interrupt the
Martian that is the cockroach in my
apartment thank you ah where is it big
guy Jesus where you can tell from the
ominous music dude the scheme I mean
what's the point
look look shooting in the legs oh it did
work what have you alright here we go
I don't have any jokes to say I just I'm
so horrified at how creepy these goddamn
monsters are oh man come on man
[Music]
that's I hate with that are there any
grenades in this game oh you can use
your slow-mo power
Oh what that move I like to give it
three stops I'd like you it's like
actually angry when you stop some they
did a good job of the stopping mechanics
in this game this is how you make wine
bet Necromorph wine Cabernet yeah that
delicious Necromorph wine
holy God oh yeah a Schmidt I could see
this would be a much easier game to play
on a PC because it's like the aiming is
not amazing on this console thing I read
the YouTube chat a bar game she's crazy
over there
the YouTube chats insane oh I will say
crazy Oh both oh come on they're trying
to tell you hands up don't shoot you're
right
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll shut up
[Music]
I find Necromorph Merlot stop tell them
to stop their heads YouTube chat I've
read you guys HS out number 7 PC is best
yes you guys exist you just get a little
rowdy sometimes launch it land
oh this is no way this is gonna go well
for old bleh
oh I see
this guy's definitely a dead guy right
that's stop a minute
what is that oh my god
oh Jesus oh it's like a weird goat
octopus dog
it's a weird goat octopus dog thing I
like him you like him give him a home
no I give him a home into hell
oh come on now they shoot stuff ah
there's a lot of them too you know it's
way easier actually shoot ouch
oh there we go give him a home what's
wrong you probably are a unit you know
morph on the side of the neck rub Tron's
or the Necromorphs are you unit on the
side of the Necromorphs what are they
called
I don't know whatever that went pretty
well well I'm gonna go save somebody's
ass again cuz everyone this game is
incompetent except for me and I'm pretty
incompetent also oh you need collagen
Unitologist exactly took the word right
out of my mouth because it wasn't in my
mouth
Beth hordes animals confirmed
I don't Unitologist thank you I'm I'm
Amadeus Conan have my children Manman
3/8 rah blocks by the way a change your
name that's way too long be he's got
children bro
[Music]
Unitron 5000 adopt don't shoot sister
[Music]
here's three more things I have to turn
on or do good I'm inside the generator
this is safe we pass spooky foster he
played outlast of Conan Beth we'll put a
link in the chat yeah you've done it it
was great super fun that was a Halloween
one yeah we did like a spooky Halloween
[Music]
up guess what I think we activated we
opened the zoo were you at where you at
we're yet I hear you
no way this is gonna go well
yep let me guess it's all screwed up
here they come here they come
I see you oh Jesus Christ
those dog octopus things are over these
guys aren't it oh look
Oh aren't we just a bunch of blood soup
yeah exactly
I'm hungry for blood I know we're gonna
give this one more shot then we're gonna
go eat lunch blood soup do you think
blood soups fattening you guys got a lot
Aaron in it all right I think I'm gonna
take these guys on the write down first
there we go let's go champs we're yet
here you come shoot him the legs regular
stop them stop them stop them
stop oh no one more one more here we go
I got this we got this
we do this then we do this
[Music]
all right let's go
nope [ __ ] you
oh my god
dis let's get some distance get some
distance let's get some distance from
these crazy creatures no eat it dick
holy [ __ ]
No thank you no thank you I do not want
any of that I do not want any of those
things thank you where are you little
octopus dog come here you bastard here
boy here boy come here yep yep oh that
sucks
yep here boy sit play dead play dead
play dead play dead whoa whoa all right
well guys come on said hopefully we can
kill them all and save the world before
the stream ends that's not gonna happen
because the stream is over thank you all
for joining us
America ah there you go bet voted
everyone so did I oh yeah if you live in
the United States exactly exactly uh
well we stomped a lot of Necromorph
skulls today I think it was a good
Tuesday thank you for joining us and
there this episode of stream KOCO will
be back on Monday with special guests
who's coming in Monday some special
people are coming uh-huh I think maybe
we have some special guests coming
Monday it's gonna be very fun uh this
game has been dead space 3 guys thank
you for joining us by Tara Luke Vader
Talia main frisky alien Joshua Wegman
Max and reap by Nature we'll see you
guys on Monday for the next Jim cut guys
see you later
you